bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode de ce nouveau format
ensemble on va se perdre sur internet
j'ai envie de vous prendre avec moi et
faire ce que je fais tous les jours
s'avère me promener sur internet pendant
plusieurs minutes pendant une heure que
je vais vous convention en ce sens
unique je pense et réagir un peu à ce
que je vois on va apprendre des trucs
qu'on va faire rigoler j'en sais rien tu
sais pas trop j'espère que ça va vous
plaire si ça vous plaît vous dirai en
commentaire donc le fait pas maintenant
parce que c'est un petit peu trop tôt
pour juger
donc c'est parti et généralement quand
je vais sur internet je commence
toujours par mon fils twitter ce qui se
dit
alors ça c'est vraiment mignon c'est des
graines qui ont une forme de coeur de
succès des graines de cardio terme ou à
la cup à l'icac à bout dans le grand
boss énormes
c'est énorme ce qui se passe et ça c'est
une branche à c ur d'une branche d'arbre
la fin de cette de cette plante là c'est
la job terrisse focus is du vietnam
voilà c'était une sélection du plant au
scope sa draft qui date de 2009
il s'agit de la part des indiens qui
veulent que leur enfant soit un garçon
est pas une fille plus la barre est
longue plus ils ont envie que ce soit le
garçon en fait on se rend compte que
plus ils ont la télé câblée et moins ils
veulent que ce soit un garçon qu'est ce
qu'on peut en déduire pas pas grand
chose
est ce que ça veut dire que grâce à
cette nouvelle source d'information ils
ont pu s'enrichir et star machin et du
coup développer certaines valeurs et que
du coup il veut peut-être moins
d'enfants + 2 me
c'est plus équilibré j'en sais rien où
ça peut aussi être du fait que bas ceux
qui sont qui ont la télé câblée sont
faites plus en ville et du coup il ya
moins de tradition c'est une corrélation
alors ce n'est pas une conséquence de
ces difficiles de dixinn physique
allez on continue notre tour l'important
sans ondes électromagnétiques le l'ifi
l'internet par la lumière disponible
pour le grand public et la lumière est
une onde électromagnétique la lumière et
une onde électromagnétique
bonne lecture bah alors on va dormir en
cours de physique
la lumière est une onde
électromagnétique nos grappes long que
les ondes électromagnétiques
c'est donc via les rayons gamma rayons x
uv lie à la lumière dans le spectre
visible ou infrarouge micro ondes fm am
grandes ondes radio tout ça c'est les
ondes électromagnétiques la lumière en
est à un moment tu vois ce qui change
entre tout ça c'est la fréquence
facebook messenger est sorti pour les
enfants je pars si vous avez vu ça donc
c'est pour que les enfants et les grands
parents puissent communiquer voilà on a
une contrôler la liste de contacts
année des fans qui a publié deux filles
cheveux etc et aujourd'hui
stan horacek se demande si ce que
laissait ses enfants utilisaient cette
application fait de mieux fait de lui un
mauvais pas c'est une bonne question
pouvait lire et je résume en même temps
j'ai une pub pour ces sleepers c'est
horrible c'est horrible il explique que
il a eu droit au fameux argument n'est
pas pas tous les amis l'utiliser tout se
plaisent je peux l'utiliser et où il
allait voir
yalda clou ce qui est en soi un
professeur de psychologie assistant à
ucla où celle ci tout son groupe d'amis
comme unique de cette façon dix sept
assistants c'est totalement ok et même
sain de laisser son enfant l'utiliser
moi je t'ai livre les informations les
baisers yat-il isr kirk oriane qui est
sarov humaines développement d'une
famille studies à l'université de
bristol city qui dit que interdire les
réseaux sociaux peut au contraire
parfois motivé l'enfant à trouver des
canaux qui sont non surveillée et donc
du coup qui sont plus risqués façon je
vous dis qui sûr qu'il me regarde moi
aussi on va pas y échapper tout ça va
être très difficile d'interdire à ses
enfants d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux
jeux même pas si c'est souhaitable
effectivement au lieu de tenir vos
accompagner les nouvelles parodies de
simples basiques
c'est ouf à cause du tsunami de 2011 et
c'est à des espèces sont retrouvés genre
sur les côtes d'amérique n genre des
espèces de mollusques est aujourd'hui
sans comprendre la position et genre
ça pourrait causer des problèmes tout
on ne pense pas simple voilà vous savez
le problème existe si vous de vous
renseigner
alors autre news youtube les trois pour
cent premiers youtube heures ou plus
grosse chaîne youtube de la plate forme
après 4 1% des vues en 2007 tout et
c'est un phénomène qui tend à
s'accentuer
j'allais dire que du coup j'allais faire
grève mais en fait changer la vie de
personnes donc on va continuer à faire
des vidéos par les homards donc pour les
faire cuire généralement les mais vivant
dans une eau bouillante pour les
bouillir et donc vous savez quoi
en fait on ne sait toujours pas ce
manque ne sais pas si ça leur fait mal
ou pas ce que je sais par contre c'est
qu'à partir de mars 2018 ce sera
considéré comme un acte de cruauté
animale de cuir homard vivant en suisse
voilà donc le fait pas il dise un truc
intéressant à 10 que la douleur c'est
dénommé nos logiques
en gros c'est à dire que la partie
moment où tu le sens tu es dedans on ne
peut pas te dire si tu sens de la
douleur ou pas n'ont cessé il ya que toi
qui peut le savoir
quelqu'un peut pas dire non
d'après la nasa l'arctique se réduit un
taux de 13 2% par décennie lg a montré
son d'un téléphone et ça va ça ressemble
pas du tout à l'iphone dit c'est cool
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu n'hésitez pas à me faire vos retours
en commentaire si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo et à
lui mettre un petit pouce en l'air ça
aide pour le référencement tout ça tout
ça comme ça c'est d'être dans le top 300
chao et continuez de vous perdre sur
internet c'est comme ça qu'on va les
trouver